I hope that works out for him I hope
that his intentions are true and I hope
that you know I personally I think he's
gonna end up with Kember named the
Canadian if he picks anybody you know
there is still that point of doubt in my
mind the way they're kind of playing
things Nick is old for three and finding
love on the Bachelorette and bachelor in
paradise and Chris isn't convinced
Nick's found love this time either
why'd you say you hope his intentions
are true it's been a long road for him
it's very easy today I mean let's be
honest once you go on the show do you
have girls that know who you are but I
know that it's not hard for Nick today
anymore and living in LA you have your
you have a lot of options but so I hope
I hope it works out for him just in
general and that he's truly you know
found somebody whether tonight's finale
ends in happiness or heartbreak all eyes
are sure to be on Nick
which press claims is exactly the way he
likes it Nick wants to be famous he
loves being famous he loves the
spotlight really truly does if he
wouldn't admit that he's lying Nick did
admit to ET earlier this season that his
bachelor journey wasn't just about
finding a soul mate there were certainly
an element of this would be a cool
experience and although his bachelor
journey ends tonight Nick isn't giving
up his reality TV fame quite yet next
for him is Dancing with the Stars or
have you talked to him giving him that
advice sorry I've talked to him I mean I
think the guy's got it down he's getting
he's kind of reality television pro he
knows what he's getting into
and he's been wanting to do this for a
long time and good for him
[Music]
you